flosse ça déménage dans la famille
laurent un nouvel appartement plus petit
mais leur permettra d'économiser 350
dollars par mois on se sent un peu plus
un peu plus à l'e3 mais au moins on
économise en économisme court jusqu'à la
veille du déménagement quand il n'avait
toujours pas de camions en raison des
prix de location au dessus de ses moyens
laura blondieau elle y ait pris davance
on a dû s'y prendre trois quatre mois
avant et on a eu la dernière place donc
la place du soir celle que personne ne
veut donc ça c'est pas trop cool et là
encore elle croise les doigts pour que
ces déménageurs trouvées sur facebook ne
lui fasse pas faux bond
c'est d'ailleurs une situation qui est
de plus en plus fréquentes note
pierre-olivier cyr du clan panneton mais
énormément d'entreprises peu fiable vont
décider plutôt de l'art chez les clients
qu'ils ont réservé au mois de janvier
février pour prendre des clients de
dernière minute qui eux sont dans une
situation de détresse et qui sont prêts
à payer plus cher
il estime au ch'ti à 60 pourtant le
nombre de rendez-vous de déménagement
liés à des rénovations c'est ça le drame
les gens qui se retrouvent en difficulté
aujourd'hui ce ne sont pas des gens qui
ont cherché à quitter leur logement
c'est des gens qui pour la plupart ont
été victimes
d'évictions d'éviction de rénovation
frauduleuses qui se retrouve à devoir
chercher et qui ne trouvent pas à se
loger ou même cri des taux
d'inoccupation des logements dans les
grandes villes du québec se situe en
dessous de sting pourtant montréal s'en
sort un peu mieux avec 3,6 pour cent de
logements inoccupés contre une
saturation remarqué dans des villes
comme trois rivières et rimouski
aujourd'hui dans toutes les habitations
toutes les ressources sont en poste
important follement désert puis
également on a donné également des
montants ou municipalité pour
entreposer des ménages et donc offrir de
l'aide également à tous ceux qui en ont
besoin 750 ménages n'avaient toujours
pas trouvé de logement à la veille du
1er juillet au québec ici daniel k jaws
radio canada montréal